okay I'm not saying that this is the
most important story of the day but I'm
going to start with it because it is the
most baffling it's the most baffling I
am baffled by it they should do an
Unsolved Mysteries on this that's how
mysterious it is so Nikki Haley who is
uh still pretending to run for president
tweeted last night a couple of messages
she received from
supporters and so far so good I mean
pretty normal I don't really see the
point in showing everybody like nice
things that two random people said to
you as if that's going to move the
needle as if anyone's going to see and
go you know I didn't like M Niki Haley
but these random people are right
actually I think I'll vote for her for
president um so but but it's still
pretty standard operating procedure um
until you get into the details so let's
look at uh at the Tweet first of all
let's pull up the te the let's pull up
the caption first of the Tweet um
Americans want a choice in this election
not a rerun I'm overwhelmed by all of
the kind words we'll keep working hard
to make you proud she says and then here
are the screenshots of the two messages
well one's an email and one is a letter
a snail mail letter that was sent to
her so here's the letter I want to
encourage Nikki Haley to keep pressing
on we need a competent and committed
leader to stay the course in a bid for
the presidency I'm an independent and I
have voted for the best candidate every
election cycle and this year it's Nikki
signed Mary a and then the next
one says please do not give up your
fight in a world that's become crazy
with we need a level-headed conservative
leader to navigate us through through
the insanity no one is more capable than
you are to write the ship and heal this
great nation we need you Nikki this
country needs you our allies and The
Beautiful People of this world need you
I don't want you to give up and I
guarantee you there are millions more
out there who feel exactly as I do
okay um so the content wise content is
pretty standard issue uh the problem is
the presentation and by the presentation
you can tell that these are
clearly 100% fake so Nikki's team made
these things up and wrote them and
posted them um and and so that's what
they just they're making up fake fan
mail for Nikki Haley and then posting it
and how do we know well first of all um
the message on line can we go back to
the message that's on line
paper we know we know this message on
lined paper is not real because that's
not that's a
font and that's not real lined paper
because like number one if somebody sent
you um like a a letter on on on paper
and then you and you wanted to post a
screenshot it would look like you took a
picture of the paper now unless we're
supposed to believe that she got this
letter in the mail from Mary a and then
she scanned it to the computer and and
uploaded it and saved it and then posted
from there but even if you did that it
still wouldn't look like
that okay so that's a
font um and I guess look if you have not
used a computer since like
1992 if your last computer was a was one
of those computers with like a small uh
a small Monitor and a and a and a
console the size of the International
Space Station and it's a black screen
with green letters you kids don't know
anything about this this is the first
computer I ever had was this we had
Tetris on the computer and you could
write on it and it was green letters
that's all you could do so if that was
your last experience with a computer
then uh you might you might be fooled by
this because you'd be like I didn't know
that you can do a font that looks like a
little bit like handwriting I had no
idea now when we got a few years later
we got a a you know another computer
it's a little bit more updated and we
had a word processor and the most
impressive technology on that computer
was the fonts you could change the fonts
you could have all these different fonts
and me and my siblings we'd have a lot
of fun just typing things and trying
different fonts and this is what we did
back in those days this is how it was
hours a day just like fun with fonts
that's what we did so but ever since
then most of us know that you can do a
handwriting font and that's what that is
and then we go to the and so that's bad
enough like that's that's made up that's
fake then we go to the email
one okay what are the problems here with
this email I I don't know where to start
uh first of all I don't know what email
screen this even is like is this if
we're going back in time is this like
AOL dialup AOL 3.0 email screen so I
don't know what email server she's even
using but it it says to Nikki Haley at
the top which there's not an email
address it just says Nikki Haley like
you could just go into your email you
know you could go to go to your internet
machine and if you want to send Nikki
Haley an email just type in Nikki Haley
and the internet will know where to send
it um and then you got the whole thing
no subject line so we're supposed to
believe that Nikki Haley is opening
emails from people she doesn't recognize
that don't have subject lines we're
supposed to believe that and then
finally of course the biggest problem is
that there's the send button at the you
includeed the send
button which you don't if this is an
email you received there would no
wouldn't be a send button the send
button is there because you typed it um
so and and they
they they specifically cropped it to
include the send button they made a
point of making sure the send button was
still there which it's just it's amazing
to me I I don't like I said I'm baffled
when you're in a business time is money
that's why I'm so excited to have ramp
as a new sponsor of my show if you're in
finance professional looking for a
better way to maximize productivity and
cut wasteful spending than ramp could be
for you ramp is the corporate card and
span management software designed to
help you save time and put money back in
your pocket with ramp you can issue
cards to every employee with limits and
restrictions automate expense reporting
and stop wasting time at the end of
every month ramps accounting software
automatically collects receipts and
categorizes your expenses in real time
so you don't have to you'll never have
to chase down a receipt again and your
employe EMP es will no longer spend
hours submitting expense reports the
time you'll save each month on employee
expenses will allow you to close your
books eight times faster ramp is easy to
use get started in less than 15 minutes
whether you have five employees or 5,000
get $250 when you join ramp just go to
ramp.com Walsh spelled rm.com Walsh
again that's ramp.com Walsh cards issued
by Sutton Bank and Celtic Bank members
FDIC terms and conditions apply I'm
baffled by it why why would you why
would you do this why would you fake the
messages and and then and then and then
go out of your way to make them look as
fake as possible you don't even have to
if you want to fake a message she could
have just copy and pasted she goes said
I just got this message from James K in
Iowa and and you just copy copy and
paste it into the actual text of the
tweet and yeah most people would
probably say that that looks fake but we
couldn't prove it you know you have
plausible deniability but when you give
us a screenshot you we know that it's
fake and here's what I don't
get like if you if you're on Nikki now
I'm gonna assume I'm Nikki Haley benefit
of the doubt I don't know why but I'm G
to assume that she that she didn't do
this that this is her team her team came
up with this which just shows you that
you know it it shows you how incompetent
like the crisis of incompetence is um
nationwide at this point and and
especially in politics right um and yeah
Nikki hil's presidential campaign is
fake it's not going anywhere but still
like
it is a presidential campaign and if
you're in politics and you're working a
presidential campaign any presidential
campaign even if you're working Doug
Bam's presidential camp like you you've
you've made it up the ladder a bit so
the people working her campaign have
made it up the ladder a bit and yet this
is how stupid they are that these are
the ideas they come up
with but if you wanted to do this and
you said okay we we want to post some
messages uh to Nikki some positive
messages that Nikki h
like C you can't find actual messages I
know that I I say nobody likes Nikki
Haley I'm I mean I was half kidding I I
like some people like her she does get a
few points in the polls right she got
her 10% or whatever it was in New
Hampshire most of them were Democrats
but like she does have there are some
people out there who like her so it's
not literally
nobody so you would think if you wanted
to post some positive messages you could
just go to your DMs or your email inbs
and find some real ones so I have to
assume from this that they couldn't find
any real ones I have to assume what
happened was they said people don't like
Nikki Haley uh you know we need to show
that that Nikki Haley is more beloved
than she really is let's go find some
positive messages and then they went and
looked and they scrolled through months
of messages and found none they could
not find one person who messaged her to
say we like you and so then they said
rather than abandoning ship on the whole
idea they said well we got to make it up
what's the most realistic way to make it
up to write our own email and keep it in
the send box and then post it so I
it's wow incredible um really incredible
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
wall show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcast